في يوم الجمعة، وجهت المنطقة الجنوبية من
نيويورك اتهامات ضدي، وأنا
أفهم مدى عمق القلق بشأن هذا الأمر،
ولكن الادعاءات الموجهة
ضدي هي مجرد
ادعاءات لأي شخص عرفني
طوال 50 عامًا من الخدمة العامة،
ويعرفون أنني ناضلت دائمًا من أجلها.  ما
هو الصواب كان مناصرتي دائمًا
مرتكزة على ما تعلمته من
نشأتي كابن للاجئين كوبيين، وخاصة
أمي، بطلي إيفانجيلينا، الرجل الذي يفعل
كل ما أنجزته، وعملت من أجله على
الرغم من الرافضين وكل
من استهان بي.  أدرك أن
هذه ستكون أكبر معركة أه حتى الآن
ولكن كما ذكرت طوال هذه
العملية برمتها، أعتقد اعتقادًا راسخًا أنه عندما يتم
تقديم جميع الحقائق، لن تتم
تبرئتي فحسب، بل سأظل
عضوًا كبيرًا في مجلس الشيوخ عن ولاية نيوجيرسي